[موسيقى]
تحرك النقابي واسع في ولايه صفاقس
التونسيه ومثله في مدن واجهات اخرى
عنوانها الابرز الخلاف المتصاعد بين اتحاد
الشغل والسلطه لاسيما بعد ايقاف احد
القاده النقابيين وملاحقه اخرين قضائيا
امر اعتبره الاتحاد استهدافا خطيرا
للمنظمه ولحريه العمل النقابي
على عجز الحكومه والسلطه في انها توضع
البلاد على السكه الحقيقيه على مستوى
الاقتصادي والاجتماعي والسياسي اليوم ثم
حمله الغايه منها ضرب الاتحاد وكتم صوت
النقابيين في نيه تمرير الخيارات
اللاشعبيه
الملفات الاجتماعيه ايضا حاضره مع التلويح
بان الاضرابات قد تكون الخطوه القادمه
للاتحاد في ظل تواصلي ما يصفه بتلكؤ
الحكومه في تنفيذ الاتفاقات الموقعه بين
الطرفين لطالما اعتبر خيار نزول الى
الشارع من قبل الاتحاد الشغل في تونس
مقياسا لحجم الازمات الاجتماعيه وتطورها
يضاف الى هذا سياق سياسي مضطرب لا يستثني
فيه الرئيس قيس سعيد طرفا في تحمل مسؤوليه
الازمه اشاره الرئيس في معرض احد خطاباته
الاخيره الى المارب السياسيه للعمل
النقابي جعلت العلاقه بين السلطه والاتحاد
تتراوح بين الفتور والقطيعه التامه
فالرئيس وصف الاعتقالات الاخيره التي شملت
عده شخصيات بالواجب الوطني لمحاسبه
المتامرين على امن الدوله
هناك التحفظ لرئيس الجمهوريه على الاتحاد
العام التونسي للشغل وعلى المبادره ويبدو
ان العلاقه سته سوء اكثر فاكثر وقد تذهب
في اتجاه القطيعه خاصه مع رغبه الرئيس في
المرور منفردا الورق المشهد السياسي في
تونس وابعاد
عما كان يقوم به خلال السنوات الفارطه من
شان سياسي
انعكاسات هذا الوضع قد تطالب مبادره
الانقاذ التي يستعد اتحاد الشغل لطرحها
رسميا مع مجموعه من المنظمات الوطنيه بغيت
ايجاد حلول للازمه الراهنه خصوصا وانها
ستوجه في مرحله اولى للرئيس قيس سعيد
ميساء الفطناسي الجزيره صفاقس تونس